[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michael podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them Tony strikes
again I wonder how long ago it was when
I actually called the Trump would win
Iowa it's been so long
ago I think it's when I realized that
Ronda santis was running for the
president of Iowa that I called Iowa for
Trump and I am I've seen enough I've
seen enough I am calling New Hampshire
for
Trump it's so dumb
listen I you know the commentary is spot
on this
morning after the fact I love it I I
love the talking heads on the left how
they're scared of just saying what you
need to say out loud like we do here on
the Tony Michaels podcast every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours I say the
part that everyone should be saying out
loud all the time repeated keep saying
it keep pounding the drum
and we would win a lot more meaning
democracy would win a hell of a lot
more last night again was not a surprise
to me at all not at all that Ronda
santis receives second Nikki Haley a
close third VC radama dingdong dropped
out and endorsed endorsed Donald
Trump and Donald Trump
won handily easily won in Iowa how
stupid are the people of Iowa now what
does this all mean what does it mean
going forward well folks this is a
primary that's the other thing that a
lot of Talking Heads even talking heads
that have been on this show a lot don't
fully understand they don't they don't
get it they don't understand this stuff
and and I I can't even believe that that
there are people out there that listen
to some of these folks talk and really
honestly it goes back to what I was
saying yesterday there's too much speech
sometimes like we have free speech in
this country we have Free Speech but
right now the problem that we have is
too much speech meaning that people are
listening to people who are talking that
aren't really saying anything and
they're just they're not they're not
really [__] thinking through what the
hell they're saying before they say
it I got called a loud
mouth on Twitter yesterday I was like
yeah so all right yeah I'm loud and I
got a mouth and I'm a loud
mouth but they they and I'll show you
I'll show you the tweets it's someone
from our side Tony you shouldn't attack
people from our side no we can't attack
people from our side who are saying
really stupid [__] we can we can because
when they say really stupid [__] that's
decoupled from what is actually
happening it makes us lose okay it makes
us lose when we could
win and last night should be a sad
reality for America I know a lot of
people are going to be super excited
last night that Donald Trump's win in
iow was so [__] pathetic it was
pathetic an incumbent I've been telling
you this for [__] months and months
and months and months and months that he
has incumbency and this morning I'm
Morning Joe that's all they talked about
is man he must have incumbency it would
be great if they just came over and
[__] listened and then just started
saying that [__] on on the TV
okay just say
it and I know I'm kind of patting myself
on the back here but I'm really highly
disappointed in in the talking apparatus
of the left of the left I'm really
disappointed in
it because even this morning they still
think Nikki Haley has a chance in New
Hampshire and she has a chance to be a
one-on-one with [__] Trump what the
[__] are you people talking about yeah
did you watch what happened last night
this guy has 91 [__] felonies he
tried to overturn the government he
tried to steal our [__] Constitution
away from us rip it up [__] on it piss
on it burn it and bury the Ashes to be
dictator and King he is saying the most
unamerican [__] thing that you
possibly could say that he wants to rule
over
us and half more than half
of the pathetic turnout in Iowa for the
Republican caucus voted for that
guy they voted for the insurrectionist
they voted for the the wannabe dictator
they voted for the authoritarian they
voted for white Christian
nationalism I keep telling you he's a
[__] symptom of the
disease and I've heard it so many times
well Tony look in in 2016 Ted Cruz won
Iowa and he didn't become
president Mike HBY one Iowa didn't
become president shut the [__] up shut
the [__] up shut the [__] up about
2012 2016 and 2000 or 2016 two 2020 and
even 2008 shut the [__] up if you're
talking about those races so long ago in
a country that doesn't exist anymore
you're a [__] [__] bonee head and the
reason why you're going to keep being
wrong in your commentary and in your
predictions is because you keep looking
back on those [__] numbers and what
happened then as if it's going to happen
now you do not you do not understand how
fascism works you don't get it and you
don't understand how Cults work either
apparently these people are lost they're
not in reality
and most of the Republican base who was
reliable before
2016 has walked away from engaging in
politics it's only the [__]
delusional that are engaging in this
stuff yes there's still moderate
Republicans out there that are reading
Facebook post and listening to the
cooler talk at
work but they're not
engaged this country can't stand that
[__] they can't stand
Trump they can't stand him don't want
him and he won't go away and the reason
why is because there's such a loud
[__] obnoxious Roar about how they
want him to be a dictator and a king and
to change all of us so they can feel
more [__] comfortable and they I mean
10 12% of the [__]
country I was school last night on
Twitter about how New Hampshire is a
different makeup of Voters than Iowa
yeah no [__]
Sherlock you don't think I know these
things [__] I heard on Morning Joe this
morning about how how Nikki Haley she's
probably probably likely not going to
win her State she's not going to win
North and as soon as she loses her State
she doesn't have a chance in
hell I told you that weeks ago these
things are not hard to predict honestly
because of fascism because of it because
of it it is so predictably
unpredictable they are not
creative they do not do original at all
at all they don't do
original so there's not going to be many
[__] Surprises with these
primaries that's been evident since he
entered the race right after Jack Smith
became special counsel right before he
was indicted in New York and then when
he was indicted in New York and they
rallied around him instead of dumping
him it was even more glaringly obvious
that Ronda santis or anyone else did not
have a [__] chance when the cult was
gonna come out to caucus or vote in the
primaries why is Tony so mad this
morning well the reason why I'm a little
pissed off is because listen all the
[__] that I have said in the last year
and a
half has come to fruition almost every
single [__] time there's been a few
things I was wrong about a
few and it's not because I'm smart or I
have a [__] crystal
ball again it's because of how Fascism
and white Christian nationalism works
that is so easy to predict what the [__]
they GNA do their whole
Foundation of their
principles the
entire building block that their party
sits on now is MAA and it starts with
the brick of
hatred every [__] time you can count
on
it and he has allowed them to be the
worst version of themselves he's allowed
white Christian nationalism to take hold
in this country in small groups and
small sects of the country and and just
metastasizes in these
communities with with pure-blooded
hatred for the other whoever the [__]
the other needs to be frankly doesn't
matter if one person one Trump supporter
one
maggot one bootlicking [__] eater
believes that the lgbtq community is the
one to hate oh boy but we got space for
you in the Republican party now oh you
want you hate black people all right we
got space for you in the Republican
party
now oh you're not you're not down for
our sort of hate well you don't get to
be in the Republican party anymore
folks we don't have two parties in this
country
anymore we
don't we have one party in this country
who believes in
democracy and we have one party in this
country that is fullon
autocratic they don't want autocracy
they are autocratic inside their
institution Jesus Christ Grandpa Hitler
got on stage last night and he what
called for Unity get the [__] Unity
Unity for what for another coup Unity
for what for camps to send people off to
camps to deport people because they're
[__] brown or
black to silence people because they
have a view because they descent [__]
you you will never never get [__]
Unity from me with fascism you can go
[__]
yourself
never will I unite with fascist you can
kiss my [__] ass it is the reason why
I speak out against Paul Ryan and Liz
Cheney and Chris Christie [__] them [__]
them never will I unite with a bunch of
[__] fascists I don't care how thin
veiled their fascism is I don't give a
[__] and really honestly this this is a
situation where he won a year ago he won
a year ago when Nikki Haley announced he
[__] beat her when Ronda santis
denounced he beat him
immediately the only good part about
this and I hope Ronda santis and Nikki
Haley stay in this race until after
super Tuesday I honestly hope they stick
in it because the more they stick in it
the more they spend these these [__]
billionaires money [__] them [__] them
let them spend hundreds of millions of
dollars to try to defeat Donald Trump
it'll be that much less money that
Donald Trump has to run in the general
election all the while he he he'll have
tons of legal fees his grift will get
thinner and thinner and thinner as it as
it is become more and more obvious that
he's gonna [__]
lose and we should encourage we should
encourage the Biggest Loser of all time
in our political discourse to join the
race and be in the race and we could
beat ass and I don't care how many times
we have to beat him I don't give a [__]
I don't care honestly as many times as
Donald Trump wants us the country the
Democracy the pro-democracy coalition to
beat him and MAA bring it the [__] on
bring It the [__] on [__] especially
after last night in Iowa that pathetic
[__]
win less than 60% of the turnout from
oh they're super
enthusiastic what have I been telling
you when this country finds out that
this [__] wants to be the dictator
and that his [__] his [__] cult
wants him to be the dictator they are
going to disengage
folks people who voted for him in 16 and
20 and would vote for him in 24 when
they really find out and they discover
that yes it is true what he is saying he
is going to try to do that [__] if he is
elected they are going to disengage and
good good [__]
him he's gonna win New Hampshire he's
gonna win South Carolina he's gonna win
Michigan he's GNA win on super
Tuesday he's gonna win the nomination
you [__]
boneheads and any anyone anyone let me
repeat it anyone suggesting that Nikki
Haley has any kind of shot in this race
is a [__] idiot so you're telling me
there's a
chance a [__] dumb Dum and if you're
still listening to people sit there and
talk about how Nikki Haley has a
chance you need to stop listening to
those
people they just want your click they
just want your [__] view they don't
give a [__] about the [__] country
they don't give a [__] about engaging
voters they don't give a [__] about the
truth they don't give a
[__] they don't give a
[__] hell at this point most of these
commentators don't even give a [__]
about being correct they don't they
don't even give a [__] about being
correct
anymore I mean it's just about how can I
how can I [__] shape a narrative to
change reality we're not Maga okay we're
not MAA there is no need to [__]
shape Shift Reality to try to form a
message and a narrative it's not that
[__] it's not that difficult it
really isn't and yes it takes a [__]
loud mouth to do
it how do you think the right does it
why do you think the left is always
pissed off at all the loud mounts on the
right because it's
effective it's effective in political
discourse It's very effective and it
wins and to claim to claim that somehow
some loudmouth yelling and screaming
about politics and pushing the correct
[__] narrative that will win because
it's just coupled to
reality that there's no
substance you are disconnected from the
American
people you are
disconnected you talk at the American
people not with
them this is kitchen table time baby we
are at the kitchen table and it is time
to talk and act like we are at the
[__] kitchen
table I would
imagine that the margin for the general
election after last night is going to be
well over 10
million for lots of different reasons
lots of different reasons I I believe
that Joe Biden will win by more than 10
million votes in the popular
vote I've been saying that for a long
time but it is very clear now because I
always say the only polls that
matter are the ones that happen on
Election
Day and last night it's very clear that
there's not enthusiasm for Trump in this
country this country [__] hates his
guts oh yeah you get the [__] you get
the staunt
Sheep oh yeah the sheep that are in it
to win it right for the very end the
ones that are going to drink the [__]
Kool-Aid you know what I mean those kind
there yeah they're re they're ready
they're [__] ready to drink that
Kool-Aid so let's give them their
[__] Kool-Aid
moment what the [__] are we scared of
you scared of trump get the [__] out of
here Joe Biden is GNA spank his ass in
November
easily with without even [__] trying
Joe Biden's gonna stomp his ass that's
right you hide and [__] watch just
like you hide and watch in New Hampshire
you hide and watch in South Carolina on
super Tuesday you just hide and watch
Donald Trump's goingon to run away with
this nomination he's going to win on the
first ballot and there ain't going to be
one to Center in that entire [__]
convention hall
period they're authoritarians they don't
want to be authoritarians they are are
authoritarians and it's authoritarian
party time for
them can you imagine if Joe
Biden only got just above
50% of the vote in New Hampshire in that
primary even in Iowa just just imagine
just imagine that Iowa in
Iowa Joe Biden will
have competition in Maryann Williamson
and Dean Phillips right just imagine
just think about it for a second let's
put the shoe on the other foot if you
want to [__] get down to talking
about [__] that ain't real let's talk
about really something that ain't
[__] real can you imagine if Joe
Biden barely broke
50% in a highly depressed and
recessed primary turnout oh my God the
turnout was [__]
abysmal
and Dean Phillips and MaryAnn
Williamson even further in the pack
would still still get a reasonable
number out of that primary can you
imagine can you imagine the talk oh my
God they'd be losing their [__]
minds they would they lose their [__]
minds
Joe Biden doesn't have any competitors
because he's an incumbent president
Donald Trump does not have any
competitors here because he has
incumbency with his cult they want him
to be the king they think he is sent
here by God their white Christian
nationalism tells them that the only
person that can save them is
Trump get with reality this is not 2020
this is not 2016 and this sure as hell
is not
2008 you dumb
[__] this is not a normal
[__] cycle and by the way it's a
primary
cycle people speaking about this
election as if it's a general election
is just
infuriating it's no wonder America and
Americans and General don't understand
politics it's no
wonder the people who who try to educate
people on politics are [__] boring
dry is a Sal tetine [__] cracker
can't even put can't even put some hot
sauce on that
[__] and the ones who are
vibrant clearly don't even understand
how [__] elections or politics are
nar have even [__]
work
clearly and yeah some of them I know and
some of them are my friends but I don't
give a [__] I don't care just because I
like them and they like me and I've
talked to them before doesn't mean
they're they're they're not telling you
a bunch of
[__] because there's a lot of
Talking Heads out there that are
watching MSNBC and then just making a
video about it watching MSNBC and then
making a video about
it my
narrative my positions have not
changed they won't
change until they have to change if
Nikki Haley wins New Hampshire which she
won't she will not win New Hampshire
folks if she wins New
Hampshire oh oh my God Nikki Haley's
gonna be the next president that's not
going to be my view Nikki Haley is not
going to be the nominee she doesn't have
a snowballs chance in hell for this
nomination neither does Ronda Santos I
told you that [__] when he got in the
race because he got in too late he
should have got in the day Trump was
indicted in New York the day Trump was
indicted in New York he should have made
the country make a decision are we gonna
go with the [__] the the guy who's
convicted with or charged with felonies
or are we gonna go with this other guy
if he would have done it that what day
and if he would have resigned as
governor of Florida before he went to
run for president of Iowa on the day
that Donald Trump was indicted in New
York he'd have had a [__] Fighting
Chance even as weird and [__] awkward
as that son of a [__]
is he would have had a
chance he missed his moment because he's
Ronda
santz he always misses his moment he
misses it every single time Nikki Haley
is the same goddamn way she doesn't have
Charisma and she's a [__] woman you
are not going to get [__] Maga and
the the fascist of the fash in the manga
[__] electorate to [__] nominate a
woman godamn
it pluck your [__] head out of your
ass it's not gonna happen Donald Trump
is gon to win New Hampshire he's going
to win South Carolina he's going to win
all of them on super Tuesday he's going
to go to the convention on
uncontested with no dissent in the
entire Hall they're going to
resoundingly stand and they're he's
going to say if you want me to be
dictator raise your hand and they're
gonna salute
him because only he can fix it don't you
remember only he could fix
it it's a Witch Hunt the Deep
State they still talk about this [__]
this
nonsense there's no Insurrection it
wasn't an
Insurrection the media media media media
they're lying to
you
brainworms are finishing up their meal
okay and these people [__] vote still
and they're going to keep voting count
on
it what we have to do I am really
excited though I I know it feels like
I'm pissed off but I am pissed off
because the narrative this
morning uh the narrative this morning is
is infuriating number one I've been
saying the same [__] for months and
months and months um and they haven't
maybe they have caught on but they just
caught on this morning um but the other
the other problem and the other thing
I'm I'm really um I'm pissed off about
is that Nikki Haley and Ronda Sanz
didn't spend more money didn't spend
more money I want them to spend these
[__] Rich donors money don't you
that's what I want instead of 160
million I wish they would have spent 400
million against Trump in Iowa for him to
win that would have been fantastic go go
spend a couple hundred million in
[__] New Hampshire and South Carolina
go do it please that's what we want I
got a special guest for you today he's
joining us to talk about the Iowa
caucus and I know a lot of people are
like tired of hearing about the Iowa
cauas um but you know there are some
exciting uh Rays of
Hope some exciting Rays of Hope because
there's not enthusiasm for Trump just
like I've been saying but there's
enthusiasm for this show I'm telling you
it's happening and everyone is back to
listen to Tony because Tony was right
Tony was right Tony was right holy [__]
and listen again I don't have a crystal
ball I'm not any smarter than anyone
else I just don't let my [__]
feelings get in the way of
reality it's just a thing I don't let my
feelings get in the way of what is to
come I just tell you what's to come
because I I see it pretty
clearly because I'm not shaped by those
feelings oh you gotta have a feeling you
gotta have a
feeling that's what you love about the
Tony Michaels podcast rather you love me
or you love to hate me don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
have some
pizza we'll be right back Mark 6 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni
hugs
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things things need
delivery pizzas come fast knock knock
who's there pizza magic eat pepperoni
hug spot Pizza your tummy say thank you
your mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's
like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ the Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of Brilliance this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast oh the king of Brilliance and I
bring you the time for the grift that's
right we're going to grift you so buckle
your Griff seat belt because we have
super Griff gummies that's super Griff
gummies they don't do [__] for you but
you should take them they taste fruity
they taste just like I don't know fruit
snacks and you might as well just go
grab you a pack of fruit snacks cuz
they'll do about about the same goddamn
thing as these things will but I'm
telling you when to get a you're going
to want to get in on these super Griff
gummies just sign up for a lifetime
membership of God knows how much at
supergrip gums. gri supergrip gums.
grift they're fantastic again they don't
really do anything for you they make you
think you're great maybe they'll make
you feel fantastic I don't know who
knows all right let's get to let's get
to the actual grift what I want you to
do is I want you to go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony mich.com go
to the very top and hit subscribe
there's the button right there you see
it see it right there that's the grift I
got just hit a button just hit a button
that's the grift I got ain't that about
a [__] and if you want to give money if
you want to actually get grifted hey
let's get in on the grift here's what
you do right now we're gonna we're gonna
do the tattoo I'm getting a tattoo on
the 26th Friday the 26 I'm getting a
tattoo on my arm of the microphone and
it says this machine kills fascism it's
actually inspired by this merch design
right here and you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and click on the tattoo
merch collection and you can get your
very own tattoo merch that is inspired
by the tattoo that will go on my arm now
if you want to see the live stream of
this tattoo go to the Tony michaels.com
click the team tattoo fund give any
amount in there any amount you want a
dollar $2 doll $3 or you can give the
the other amounts and you and get your
email in there and I am going to put on
the list to get the live stream links so
you can watch me get my tattoo live
maybe I'll cry I don't know you'll get
this you to see me cry who has I'm
getting a tattoo that'll be worth a buck
right or $2 Five Doll that' be worth it
to watch me cry maybe I'll even if I
actually am not crying maybe I'll
pretend to cry for you all right so
that's the Griff to that's the actual
Griff today but go get
your [__] love this go get your super
Griff gummies
because you know that you can't make it
a single [__] day without the Griff
gummies because you'll feel like you did
the day before if you don't if you don't
take them it'll be the same it's it's
just they're just they're just [__]
fruit snakes that's all they are they're
just [__] fruit snakes they're just
fruit
snacks speaking of fruit snacks boy
there was a lot of fruit snacks in Iowa
last night maybe not I don't know what
am I saying fruit snacks in Iowa um a
lot of people are confused about the
caucus process I know there's one guy
that probably knows a little bit about
caucus process
right I'm sure but there's one guy that
knows it Cliff Sher Cliff Sher my buddy
is here Cliff how are you my friend I'm
doing damn well how are you I'm doing
great I'm doing great I'm a little
pissed off about the coverage of the
Iowa caucus last night and the reason
why is because they're saying the [__]
this morning that I've been saying for
months and I'm like Jesus [__] Christ
but they just they really they always
miss the mark you know what I mean say
they I assume you mean the usual media
yeah well anyone any well there's
there's there's several different
targets that I have there is there is
the the mainstream media um which most
mornings if I'm gonna listen to MSNBC
I'm gonna listen to jod scarber talk out
his ass I'm gonna listen to that and
then all their commentators really not
not be spot on about it but I don't know
why I mean this will probably come back
to haunt but I don't really care I I
don't know why you would do that to
yourself in the morning well I like to
torture myself for years for years Cliff
I actually and this is the reason why
probably I'm I'm so spoton uh about the
rightwing is because I listen to rushing
ball almost every single day three hours
a day I listen to Sean Hannity and again
I would vly disagree with him may be
yelling and screaming at the radio you
may have brain damage from that you
realize possible that may be Rush
listening to just listening to Rush limo
raises your lip level and causes CTE it
might it might be hankering for
oxycotton too so you should keep that in
mind it's possible it's possible now you
know I'll say because I to finish it off
I listen to I mean I just can't watch
cable I do I I put it on nights like
last night for an hour or two when I
need election results and then less than
that and that's even all I can take so
there'll be more watching it this year
when there are nights primary nights and
election nights whatever but like I
can't I just I can't do regular cable
news I don't care Lefty right I just to
me it's all so dumb um the right-wing
stuff yes when I was a young pup and
getting into this business oh my God I
watched henned and combes and O'Reilly
every night and eventually went on both
their shows and got handy to ban me
because I called him an [__] well he
is an [__] he is an [__] closing
credits uh um you know well I just was
making fun of him and saying he was full
of [__] and you know I didn't use that
word but I I was saying he was full he
was full of crap because it was actually
this is how long ago this was I can take
you back it was Carrie versus uh Bush
and he was calling Carrie a flip-flopper
because that was their lie on Carrie and
I started pointing out all the things
that bush changed his opinion on and it
got it got hity really mad that I had
this like stream of Consciousness I
named about 15 things that bush had
changed everything he ever believed on
just suddenly and and so Hannity got
pissed and you know called me some sort
of a name and I called him a name it was
just
and uh he told his people I was banned
forever coming back on his show I'm sure
I'm sure I I'm sure you're broken about
it I'm sure you're broken up about it
let ask hurts man it still hurts let me
ask let me ask you something and I went
on a riy show he grabbed my ass so I'm
kidding oh well he grabbed everybody's
asses come on that's a I shouldn't make
jokes about that though he's an evil man
he is a piece of [__] and you know news
Nation loves him now news Nation this
new I don't know who they are but they
they love him now him I'm sure they
right see we don't know who they are we
don't know where their money comes from
they say dumb [__] right probably right
way well it's the it's it's the next Fox
News because news nation is waiting for
Fox News to fall here here's what I want
to ask you from last night um and then
I'll tell you my answer to this question
what what was the thing that surprised
you the most about last night what was
the one thing that you were like oh okay
I didn't see that coming was there
anything in particular I'll admit that
um
that Frozen meatball Des santz actually
ended up pulling ahead and coming in
second
really I I thought often in Iowa you
know there's in at least in the past
there's been a great sort of divide
right and there are people who were sort
of hyped but if they fail they fail big
now he did kind of fail big because
Trump got like 51% of the vote or
whatever he still got his butt handed to
him he lived up there for however long
ignored his home state didn't you know
did not that that in a way his ignoring
his mist is probably better than his
governing it so you could you could take
that as a win maybe it's a win-win but I
was I thought I thought in the end that
Nikki Haley would beat I actually I
actually believe that Ronda santis would
get second because he was running for
president of Iowa and normally when you
run for president of Iowa then you
normally come in first or second I mean
that's that's pretty that's pry there's
a corollary to that rule it's called the
Rong to s's personality well that is
true that is true well when you meet
when there's somebody who by actually
meeting them you you want to vote for
them exponentially less I thought that
that might be a situation where he went
there to meet everybody and honestly
like meeting him I think I said the
other day you know when he on Twitter
was offering like come up and be here
with Rona santis and meet me and do
whatever and I was like I would rather
watch flies [__] that's pretty much how
I feel about I you know there's I
honestly there's George Carlin I have to
give credit he w't there's a lot of
things in life especially in politics
where I would rather watch flies [__]
but it's so important that I gotta kind
of leave the fly porn for later you know
I I I do that on my own time you got to
put the fly porn aside you gotta put
yeah right to pay attention to
like I just was on Stephanie Miller's
show who's a good friend and um she uh I
got into the the I got into Trump's
shark porn you know uh because of uh he
wanted stormmy Stormy Daniels to watch
Shark Week with him because he was so
obsessed with it and I took it all the
way back to a joke from friends I don't
know you ever watched it where there's
like where where the late Matthew Perry
he's going to uh you know he's going on
these his job is sending him to like
Tulsa yeah and and she comes to visit
him in Surprise and he's watching por
watching ches he just hits anything on
the channel and it goes to the Shark
Week Channel she sees him with a big b
watching she figure out ways to turn
them on with sharks so so now I've
discussed both shark porn and fly porn
that's a pretty impressive day well I
mean and it's it's just it's not where
you're at it's it's not even one o'clock
yet you haven't even probably had lunch
so you're doing pretty good if I could
discuss two various forms of non-human
porn before lunch it's like that old
army you know before 9:00 a.m. I'm I
mean we might get into some more porn
before we break here but here here's
here's the thing here's the thing it's
nothing nothing surprised me really in
Iowa um I figured it was going to break
the way it broke I I figured the the um
the turnout was going to be down because
the enthusiasm behind Trump is is dismal
uh and like you said the santis no one
gives a [__] about that guy um the only
people that give a [__] about the santis
the guys that give a [__] about the
santis are the ones who [__] hate
Trump and Nikki Haley is so
uncharismatic you have to you know you
have to actually which makes me there
was a lot of money spent in Iowa no I
know which makes me think he's probably
paying his wife because I can't believe
she really gives a [__] about him so
like anybody who likes the santis is
being paid to like him well do you know
what I actually you know that's not a
bad narrative I actually think that um
it's actually I think true but yes we'll
keep it as a narrative too I think I
think Ron right well sometimes narrative
is true sometimes it's it's just a
glimmer of the truth but I actually
think that Ronda sanz's wife what's name
Casey is that her name is that her name
she actually wants to be first lady more
than he wants to be president God she's
like she's like watch all the old stuff
all she's she is want to be jacn bo so
desperately she's like like the white
gloves they actually match his white
booties so it's kind of a nice thing
right well I mean you know when you're
when you're dressing up uh in Cosplay
for for being the first lady it's good
that your husband would match you um and
you know of course um you know Nikki
Haley um could you know she she didn't
do as well as she wanted to do up there
um but that's because she was wrong she
thought that that when she went up to to
Iowa there'd be slaves ready to help her
uh work on her her campaign she she
doesn't know anything about slavery
because that's not what the Civil War
was about so she it wasn't so it wasn't
about that so I think she thought it
still existed and she actually find some
slaves to help in her campaign when she
couldn't it all it all fell through well
now we have to keep bringing this up I'm
sorry I'll make jokes about it to do it
but she she can never live down the well
there was there were economic
difficulties caused by a lack of
industrial output and trade and slavery
right you know so in any case we're
gonna and and although I will say this
one thing as much as um she seems to
love the old Confederate slavery system
interesting thing is people still
perceive her as the moderate um and in
Republican par these days that means um
you poop yourself once a it right um
right and but and you probably you know
don't just push the nuclear codes for
fun um but in any case moderate moderate
this is right this is actually a fun
point and I think you what I should have
led with this when you said what was the
most surprising thing to me the most
surprising thing about last night was
the exit polls that showed that 43% of
Nikki Haley voters were open to voting
for Joe Biden well and again this that
is incredible when you think about I
don't mean to cut you up but just people
need to understand who don't get how
white like Iowa is
like Iowa as I I'm gon just steal I
can't come with something else I'll L I
live in Iowa's basement I live in
Missouri so I live in Iowa's basement so
I know exactly how you actually have
people of color right I I know I know
but I have family from Iowa Northern
Missouri which is basically Iowa like it
is so I'll just say if to to how I
described it in the last show I was I'm
sorry to reuse the line but Iowa is like
cocaine on top of snow in Utah white
right is what we're talking about and
and so and then it is heavily those who
turn out Republicans very Evangelical so
even obviously that population loves
Trump more because they all believe in
Cults together but the point is still
that some of them because it's such a
heavy Evangelical white population some
EV white evangelicals some white
conservative Christians whatever
whatever must have come out and voted
for Nikki Haley and 43% of them are
saying they're open of Joe Biden and a
third go ahead well I was gonna say that
these these are all good points they're
not surprising to me I've been saying
for a long time that look the enthusiasm
for Trump is way down this country
[__] hates his guts they don't want
to listen to him they don't want to hear
him and most of the country has
disengaged in politics because of him
and because of that because the one
thing they don't want to do is get in a
conversation in their White Town in Iowa
with another white cracker that looks
like it walked out of a Saltine package
right and try to have a conversation
politics huh your joke was better than M
and you know this Saltine cracker that
wears a red maganga hat they don't
really want to have a conversation with
that person about politics they'd much
rather keep it light and white you know
not not having to [__] defend their
political position in public and really
that's the thing that I want to get to
with the Iowa caucus which I think a lot
of people were discounting including
every single talking head and every
single person in the media who thought
Ronda Sanz or Nicki Haley or VC rad
damama dingdong had a [__] chance
here's how caucuses work you get in a
big [__] room right and everyone it's
obvious who you're gonna [__] vote
for it is obvious go into different
group right right so you're not going
into a voting Bo teams at you know at
recess it's like that you're like you're
on Trump's team you're on you know and
you go to your different areas right now
I don't live in a cauas state but I know
how cauas works right and a lot of
lefties online have been watching people
uh dump their their slip their vote into
paper bags and like oh my God I'm like
what how don't you know this how
caucuses work they're in a spot where
they're going to vote for that person
it's not a [__] secret it's not a
secret ballot you're not secretly voting
you're just sticking your slip of paper
in that bag so they can count the slips
instead of counting people because they
want to count the slips that you wrote
on it's not complicated it's not be
outlawed by the
way what's that oh I mean caucus yeah I
mean the whole whole thing about a cauc
first of all in a caucus in Iowa is the
most ludicrous non-sample of normal
people like you might as you might as
well get the people that cut off their
own nuts and went up to the halop comet
all right like some cult like that let's
start with that um but but caucuses in
general as you just said they're there
you have to be because you're not just
going to vote right like I'm gonna go
vote which hope you hope most people do
right you stand in line you prove you're
a voter you go you grab your ball
dedicated [__] who's willing to hang
out for hours try to persuade other
people to come over to your side and I
mean so who is that I'm not even willing
to do that so I mean it's like the
smallest percentage of people it's like
hi I'm a loser who has no interests
whatsoever but I'm really angry so I
think I'm gonna go to a caucus stand up
for my guy threaten other people and try
to get them to join me right well and
that's the thing when you said threat
because the thing that I knew is that
there's a lot of people who wanted a
caucus for Des santis and Haley that
probably caucused for Trump and the
reason why and the reason why is because
MAA sends bomb they try to shoot and
kill you they scared they W up through a
burning cross on lawn and a bunch of
guys wearing pillow [__] it's [__]
Iowa okay it's Iowa white people in Iowa
don't have black people to be scared of
they have other [__] crazy ass white
people to be scared of and those crazy
ass white people are the ones who are
showing up to caucus who are the
craziest ones who are the most violent
ones the Trump people so they show up
they're the ones who are doing the most
threatening I'm not saying there aren't
any among the other groups but we know
the the vast majority of them are most
likely to be Trump people and people to
live in that community and they're
scared so they get peer pressured into
doing this so again caucuses in general
in Iowa it's even worse all right but in
general they are the Stu I mean there
look like Town Halls real Town Halls not
the dumb things we do for TV like old
New England Town Halls where someone
would come and and
and answer questions right yeah answer
questions and propose ideas for
legislation they might support in the
legislature and actually seek people's
you know input and that kind of thing
it's it's something of a bygone age we
are a country of 330 million 340 million
people caucuses are [__] dumb all
right when you had like eight million
people in the country and and if you got
a few thousand people there in your
state of like you know 14,000 people
that might be representative of
something maybe South Dakota is still
small enough in population and large
enough in sheep population that you
you could have a caucus and it might be
representative or there were plenty of
sheep that showed up last night there
were plenty of sheep but not enough most
places it's not representative of
anything it's stupid it is
anti-democratic at its very core right
well and and the other thing too about a
about a caucus is that when you have a
low turnout it does give an indicator of
low enthusiasm that's the one thing that
you will guarantee with the caucus a lot
of people like oh but the weather was
really cold I'm like it's Iowa it's
always [__] cold what are you talking
about I they're used to being [__]
cold what are you talking about just
because Matt gats marjerie Taylor green
and Jim Jordan went there and they were
cold doesn't mean Ians doesn't know what
cold is they knows what the cold is they
got so if we're being honest if you've
seen both Jim Jordan's sort of head
shape and margerie Taylor green Spork
feet you know they both live in Center
Earth so when they come outside of
Center Earth it's freezing right that's
true that's true that is true that is
true the deepest depths of hell are a
hell of a lot hotter than Iowa On Any
Given date no matter how cold it may be
um so I want to move on just a bit to
the next primary because we do have an
actual primary that's going to happen uh
the next one and it's New Hampshire now
I'm G to put you on the spot and make
you make predictions here I'll tell you
my predictions first uh Trump will win
New Hampshire he will win New Hampshire
uh easily it handily Nikki CH Haley does
not have a chance in New Hampshire and
neither does meat ball Ron even come
close to even [__] dunking on New
Hampshire now here's a good news that I
want to tell Chance New Hampshire Me Bon
I think he's talked to fewer people
there well that is true so they might
not they might not know how weird he is
chance
there well that that you know I didn't
think about that so that might surprise
me but here's the thing is that everyone
is discounting and the media at this
morning when I was listening Morning Joe
they said it over and over and over he's
somehow the incumbent I've been saying
this months I'm like look there's an
incumbency built in what do you think
the big lie is what do you think him
continuing to say that I won he lost I
won he lost is to make them believe that
he won and they lost and if you didn't
look at what happened last night and go
well the enthusiasm for Trump and
overall is way down but the enthusiasm
for Trump inside the manga cult is way
up like they love the guy they want him
to be king dictator they want to lick
his b balls even as crazy as that might
sound that's what they wanted but pretty
freaking gross I'll tell you that my
guess is he'll win New Hampshire do you
think Nikki Haley has a chance in New
Hampshire do I think she has a
chance but um no she's not gonna win um
look the the difference in New Hampshire
and this is important Independents are
allowed to vote in either Party primary
the Democrats don't have a real one
because they have some weird woman
looking at Crystals uh showing up there
and uh and we've chosen to have more
representative States than the two two
very white States go first anyhow um but
but so any Independents there who want
to make their voices heard are more
likely to vote in the Republican primary
right so they're going to vote in
Republican primary and they're more
likely to pick Nikki Haley because she's
again the proslavery moderate so they're
gonna but I I think I think her our pro
slavery position may hurt them a little
bit among Independents but they still
like her because they're moderates for
Republicans right so I think that that
in the end I'll predict it again Watch
I'll get it wrong again I actually think
she'll the Trump will win I think she
will beat beat out uh uh uh meat B Ron
uh and come in second because of
Independence like McCain P an upset of
of bush there because of all the
independence or whatever I mean it was a
different Republican party then still
sucked but a little less crazy um but
but I think in the end I think she
actually will come in second there she
harded there because she knows
Independence can vote uh and I think
meet Bon comes in third and the only
question at that point becomes when does
he drop his ass out he probably thinks
because he's Southern he can hang on and
maybe come in come in second you know
well I don't know how he thinks he's
coming in second in South Carolina but
I'll make the bigger prediction to than
this Trump wins in New Hampshire um
Nikki hilly does the best she could
possibly do and maybe only loses by 15
to 20 points but then Trump goes down
and beats her in her home state of South
Carolina just the way he beat Marco
Rubio to a pul and embarrassed the hell
out of him in Florida by 20s something
points or whatever in the end when when
the the core base in South Carolina is
as right-wing and racist and nutty
remember leat water from down there
that's where when McCain won in in New
Hampshire that's when they went and they
they did the whole black love child and
all that stuff to to to help bush win in
South Carolina and get back on track to
win the the stuff they will be saying
about Nikki Haley is stuff that no other
Republican has ever said about Nikki
Haley before in concentrated doses they
will be called I'm sure they'll be
calling her an illegal immigrant I'm
sure they're you know illegal as that's
their term not mine just to be clear I'm
sure they'll be saying all sorts of
stuff like that and and I'm going to
predict she will lose and that they will
say her real name instead of Nikki
they'll callada I don't remember the
last name and in the end that is where
Trump will put this thing away right but
so so that that is a that is a good
prediction here's what I hope happens I
actually don't think this will happen I
I I I I predict that Trump will win by
15 or 20 in New Hampshire um I think I
think Nikki Haley beats Ron very very
easily I'm hoping though that Ron is
just a few points behind Niki Haley and
the reason why I want Ron right up
behind Nikki Haley is because I want Ron
to go to South Carolina I want him to go
to South Carolina I want him to keep
spending Republican donors money and I
want him to spend as much as he possibly
can [__] fathom that he can spend
their money because folks that's really
the game here is that Republican donors
are are gonna get really sick of giving
money to Nikki Haley and Ronda santis
for these what you would call Vanity
campaigns as in they're they're trying
to get Trump but I hope that Ron because
if Ronda santz holds on to South
Carolina and he can get very close or
beat her in South Carolina some way
somehow because Trump has been just
destroying Nikki Haley then that'll keep
Ronda santis in until super Tuesday um
and the reason why I want that is
because I want Trump to have to spend a
shitload of money on super Tuesday I
want Ronda santis to have to spend a ton
of money on or on super Tuesday or Nikki
Haley either one I just want them to
spend as much of their [__] campaign
cash as they possibly can spend that's
all I want that's all I want because two
things to to that I you know thoughts on
that and and one is I fully agree with
you obviously the more money that they
waste on their effectless Pursuits of
the presidency good more Republican
money wasted second thing is Ronda sandz
is hilarious I mean I don't want him
going right our content's gonna suck if
he if if how boring is this he is
unintentionally that guy who went up and
gave him the participation trophy I mean
chef's kiss like I I want the santis in
there because it's it's you just it's
like I'm trying to think of how to
describe it man it's you're it's like
one of those characters that you know
all the other Mobsters pick on in a mob
movie you know like Joey numnuts or
something and they're all just insulting
him and the minute he sort of like he's
he's sort of sitting there looking down
and the moment he sort of speaks back
they just shoot him you know what I mean
like like he's he's just the loser of
the group he's only there because his
you know his mom's the sister of the big
mob leader and like they all know he's a
total tool and that's the way everybody
acts towards the santis and I want that
to continue because I find it hilarious
right so well I mean every every group
of friends has the one friend that they
have in their group so that way they can
laugh at them you know just don't be
that friend Ron don't be that friend but
you know stay in the race buddy as long
as you can spend that spend that Haron
Hitler cash spend that you know I want
Nikki Haley to spend all that coke
brother money just spend it baby just
spend spend spend spend spend that way
there's less of it uh when we come
around because I really think and to end
it here I want to say that I'm making a
prediction that I think Joe after seeing
the result of last night I'm I'm
satisfied i' I've heard i' seen enough
Trump will win New Hampshire he'll win
South Carolina he'll win every state on
super Tuesday he will win the nomination
and he will lose by more than 10 million
votes in the general election uh he will
lose by more than 10 a margin of 10
million it was almost 8 million last
time and it' be more than 10 million
this it' be fun to argue with you
because we have fun doing it but I fully
agree it's going to lose by 10 million
votes and I think in the end also he
will been convi convicted of at least
two Crimes by then I'm going to predict
that and uh that by the time the general
comes around and I think he will lose
states that Republicans have started to
count on he'll lose Georgia and Arizona
um and Nevada and whatever but I believe
he's also going to lose at that point
being a felon with onethird of Iowa
voters saying if he was found guilty of
felonies that they would not vote for
him I think that's going to translate to
the rest of electorate I think the seven
points that that Republicans have lost
on average in elections since abortion
was overturned is going toit and I think
he's going to end up losing Texas I
think he's gonna lose Florida I think
there's a good chance he's gonna lose my
home state here of Ohio hell it may go
far enough that Missouri's back in play
Baby wouldn't that be cool and there's
there's a lot of down ballot races that
are super important for that enthusiasm
for that turnout and for that un
enthusiasm for Trump Cliff tell us where
the audience can find you tell us where
that way they can the links below but
tell us where they can find you uh best
place at CER which is the YouTube
channel uh where we do fun videos like
this and you know other fun videos that
are slightly different than this um You'
find me Cliff Shor on Twitter and Cliff
dor on threads and I think those are the
best buts but as I always say at seor on
YouTube because that's the one we're
working on trying to grow so well the
YouTube link is down below in the
description go to YouTube just type in
gor you'll get there or come to this
video look at the description down below
Cliff thanks for joining me I I know
it's not Thursday but I wanted you to
join me to talk Iowa because I couldn't
laugh about Iowa today what do we really
have in our lives that's right that's
right I appreciate it thanks for having
me on man come come back soon my friend
we'll see you soon everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy P's mail
do you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul goar and thanks to my
new product paron blanket I've got you
covered paron blanket specifically Works
to make you feel safe and cozy after
your involvement on January 6th and if
you're one of the other other members of
Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup par and blanket will
protect you too paron blanket is made of
a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast go to the Tony michaels.com
that's right the Tony
michaels.com get in on the tattoo live
stream that's right you can watch the
live stream of me getting tattooed not
this Friday but next Friday that's
January 26 in the afternoon I'll be live
streaming several times that afternoon
while I'm getting my microphone this
machine kills fascist tattoo as
inspired by this great merch you can go
to the Tony mich.com and grab this merch
as well this machine kills fascist the
microphone tattoo will be placed on my
arm next week the 26 so go to the Tony
michaels.com just pan on down click the
team tattoo fund give any amount any
amount at all a dollar$ two doll $10 $
five dollar if you want to do the the uh
allotted amounts that are already
automatic you can do those as well any
amount of money will get you on the list
to watch the live stream of me get
tattooed it's going to be really cool um
and all the money that you give in the
tattoo fund every single bit of it will
go to the artist every single bit of it
is going to go to the artist no matter
how much gets piled in there it's all
going to go to the artist H So and I've
got a hoodie for the artist I can't wait
to give give him that I can't wait for
you guys to meet this artist I'll
introduce them next week on social media
and on patreon so if you guys want to
follow me on patreon just go to the Tony
michaels.com pan on down you can follow
me for free but it really helps out the
show if you buy a membership if you can
afford it if you can afford it buy the
membership your support is what keeps
this microphone powered on against
fascism every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours and when you join the patreon
as a member you get access to the Sunday
rant the Sunday rant and you get access
if you join the $20 tier or higher you
get access to the Discord server and the
producers corner on the Discord server
now it the Discord server is free you
can just join it you just you just click
on it here and then it'll it'll take you
there let me let me see if I can get you
the the link
here I'll put it in the chat here you
can join the patreon or you can join the
Discord at this link right here I'll put
it in the chat there so you guys can
have it see it and go to it and join it
and also don't forget the book club uh
they were doing Rachel mat's book
yesterday uh and they're going to do
we're hopefully we're going to do Rachel
Matt's book hit them where it hurts in
February when that book releases with ra
Dr Rachel mattow or excuse me Dr Rachel
boffer I was mixing mattow and boffer
you see how that works because they're
Rachel
oh Rachel madow and Rachel
boffer all right let's get back to some
stuff there's some news there's some
breaking news couple bits of breaking
news KY Cheney has it here on Twitter I
actually think this is um big news big
news here it is ky cheny has it just in
a split bench of the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals has rejected Twitter's
appeal of the ruing granting jacksmith
access to Trump's Twitter feed which I
think is very important when you
consider he was probably dming people
during the coup I think that's the the
biggest thing is the actual messages
that lie and this is why Twitter wants
to protect this is because Elon is very
concerned that he would give evidence
against Trump to show that it was
actually a coup which kind of destroys
the whole narrative that the media is
lying to you and there's the Deep State
and blah blah blah you know all that
[__] nonsense that the right-wing
spreads around um so that's some pretty
good news and you know I'm not just one
to just tell you any and every motion
that
happens um but that that is a step
forward because I believe what lies in
Trump's DMS is the evidence that will
show that yes he knew what was happening
he planned what was happening he was
part of what happened he wanted to
overturn the government he wanted to
become dictator he wanted to overturn
the election results he wanted to steal
your democracy he wanted to steal your
vote I believe that the evidence could
lie in those DMS uh of that
I don't know maybe I'm wrong
but the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
seems to believe that it's
relevant
so um let's let's see here's here's um
and to give you another piece of the
news here K Cheney also reports the
Court's
conservatives okay say the ruling short
Change Trump's right to excert except
executive
privilege
that's damaging as well um so thank you
Kyle for keeping us up on that news uh
let's see what is this
one oh yes the immunity case it got
rejected too I'm not I don't I I we knew
that the immunity case would get
rejected by the court of appeals um we
we covered the narrative inside the
meeting where I mean when Trump's
attorney was like yeah the president of
the United States the president of the
United States can order SEAL Team Six to
kill and assassinate their political
opponents and he's immune because he's
the
president and he's using his
presidential power to assassinate his
political
opponents that one wasn't going to go
well they they don't have immunity from
murdering people can't just assassinate
your political opponents it's not a
thing those are unlawful orders which
makes it illegal which doesn't give you
immunity okay so um which again this is
going to get all the the blue libes out
there really excited um that court case
oh they're going to be super excited I'm
sure on Twitter right now they're
[__] running laps running
laps that he lost in the court of
appeals for presidential immunity
which it was pretty obvious I think the
bigger Court decision today out of the
um court of appeals is this Twitter the
Twitter DMS that's probably the one that
has a more significant uh impact of what
truly is the truth which is that he
tried to overturn the government and he
tried to commit a coup the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup that is
so all right let's see we got some um we
got some I wish I could play this video
oh my God so there's a video going
around Twitter right now of I think it's
the guy's
dad um I think it's you know I'll show
you a Ste a still a still image of it
here that way you can see it and then
you can go to and I'm gonna tell you
what happens in this thing uh I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna spoil the whole
thing because it's like a great 54
seconds like there's so much packed
inside this 54 seconds it's incredible
all right so here's a still image of it
actually you know what let's go out
there let's zoom in on this all right
right so you see the guy with the
handgun here he's got a Sig in his mouth
okay he's got a Sig in his mouth right
and you can see the the the the laptops
going here the the young man I guess I
guess is his son is sitting on the bed
okay and his dad's really pissed off
he's got a gun and he's got a cigarette
in his mouth right now again I'm trying
to have fun here so just hang on bear
with me here bear with I know a lot of
people are like does this have anything
to do with politics [__] I don't know I
mean it's the guns it's always the guns
stupid always it's the guns but if you
see Mom here in the background she's got
her [__] pants around her ankles
now later on in the video just a few
seconds after this again there is so
much packed inside this [__]
video it's incredible one of the best
videos I've seen now I can't show show
it on YouTube here um because and I
don't probably not Facebook or maybe
even twitch I don't know I'll break like
four [__] uh terms of service so I'm
Gonna Leave You in suspense that you're
gonna have to go watch this thing now if
it was politics and there was a chance I
get banned I'd go ah and play it
but it's not politics so I'm just having
fun but Mom here has her [__] shorts
around her ankle now this makes me think
that this video is quite it's not it's
not new they just didn't make this
yesterday cuz it is [__] freezing
everywhere in this country [__]
freezing no matter where you're at so I
highly doubt I really highly doubt that
um these people uh are anywhere where
it's cold but she's got her pants around
her ankles now some may think that maybe
Grandpa s cigarette here was having his
way with her maybe and maybe that's why
the sun is mad you know I don't know but
um makes me think maybe she was taking a
[__] too it is possible she was taking a
[__] while all this was going down it's
100% possible
[Laughter]
um let's see hang on let me I I'll get
the link to you I'll get the link to you
all right so um you can see here though
that he's got a Sig he's got a gun and
he's going to threaten the sun with the
gun he points it at him a couple
different times he actually fires the
gun in the clip okay he fires the gun in
the clip but what I want you to do
here's what I want you to do I want you
to go to Twitter and I want you to
comment I'm gonna I'm gonna post the
I'll post the link here hang on I'll
post the link I'll post the link in the
chat and we can post in the Discord and
stuff too and then you can go and tell
me if you think or or who this person
you I want you to go to Twitter if you
have Twitter I want you to go there and
tell me if you think this per who you
think this person votes for all three of
these people um they clearly are
inebriated in this clip again there's so
much there's so much juiciness in this
clip there's so much Maga in this clip
there really is so much maanga in this
now I know people like this I know
people like this I'm encounter people
like this I've known them in my life um
and it's wonderful
it's wonderful to
watch a video of a bunch of [__]
idiots waving around a gun and firing it
off it's really stupid it really is but
you should go watch it it's going to go
viral you're gonna see it
eventually you're gonna see it
eventually so go and and if you want you
um you can post it in the Discord here
I'll let the I'll let the laboratory
post it in the Discord there it is you
can post that in the Discord all right
let's move on to uh another clip here is
um here's Ben Shapiro uh man the
groundbreaking commentary on Iowa is so
[__] oh my God the hot takes are so in
honestly if you've been watching my show
none of this was a hot take none of it
was hot take she didn't [__] you
didn't give a [__] you're like wow that
happened
just the way he said it would happen but
here's Ben Shapiro's take on it I'm not
going to make you watch the whole thing
just a little bit well folks will'll
obviously full analysis of all the
results from the Iowa caucus tomorrow on
the bencho sh make sure tomorrow on
tomorrow a full analysis tomorrow we
will have a full analysis
tomorrow listen I'm not going to give
you an
analysis of Iowa I'm not going to give
you analysis and write down the numbers
and show you the numbers and show you
grass and the counties and how
many because I'm sure none of you really
give a [__]
and you shouldn't give a [__] about our
total [__] breakdown of Iowa it's
over it's over Iowa's done it's over
there's no need to have a breakdown
because Trump's GNA win New Hampshire
he's gonna win South Carolina he's going
to continue to win he's going to be the
nominee there's no reason to break this
[__] down there's not there there's
there's a now what you want is you want
to have the narrative correct right you
want to go forward with the narrative
correct out Iowa but there's no need to
break it down keep going there [__] box
on the bencho show to make sure
here is the very quick story Donald
Trump wins walking away all the poers
called this thing pretty much as soon as
the open that raises question in of
itself about procedure whether that
affects the final boat tally it doesn't
none of that none of that happens none
of that is real none none of that that
you just said is real because it's a
caucus it's a it's a caucus it's a
[__] caucus okay and they are like
Cliff said it's [__] weird it's
[__] crazy that they still do a
caucus it's it's kind of dumb because
you could actually get so much better of
a vote and so much better of a gauge of
who the people want in your state if you
just did like an actual election like
you could get a real sense of what the
people in that primary who they actually
want it would be much easier but you
know who's to say they get to choose how
they do their primaries and that's what
they want to do so who the [__] are we
to say it's their
Liberty to have a caucus is dumb it is
but this is one of the reasons why it's
dumb Ben the reason why it's dumb is
because the there isn't
this really strict Pro procedure there
isn't there isn't one um Paul Young says
stat rights Tony yeah states rights but
it's the party it's the state party that
gets to
decide that's that's that that's and
honestly there's some people on the left
who clearly don't understand these are
primaries and clearly don't understand
how they
work they don't they just don't you you
go and you listen to a lot of them you
listen to a lot of them a couple times a
week I mean it's your it's your right
and your Liberty to go listen to other
comment I'm not going to say you can't
listen to them you could only listen to
me but I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna point
out when they're completely wrong people
on the L don't understand that these are
primaries this is Republican primaries
once you have that about you and you
know the facts like there's a cult it's
alive and it loves fascism and the cult
leader loves to feed his sheep he loves
to feed his sheep and the Sheep love to
eat they're fat [__] sheep I don't
know if you've seen these people they're
humongous sheep
humongous line is they were doing that
based on the entrance polling data
Donald Trump is way out ahead Donald
Trump is so far out ahead at the rest of
the field can't even see him this is
secretar against the rest of the field
in the 1973 Belmont Stakes what does
that mean going forward it means that
hang on hang on hang on what did he just
say did he just refer to a [__] an
actual horse race back it up back it up
let me show you how how [__] Elite
this guy thinks he is listen is they
were doing that based on the entrance
polling data Donald Trump is way out
ahead Donald Trump is so far out ahead
at the rest of the field secretary
against the rest of the field in the
1973 St what does that and what does
that what does that mean because no one
knows what that means because most
people don't give a [__] about horse
racing or the S
1973 horse race that Secretariat was in
most people don't give a [__] they don't
give a [__] and this is the other
problem that the right has with like
this [__] box and the other problem that
the left has now I like that the right
has the problem this problem with him I
like that I like that because these
people out there who think that this guy
is their [__] their talking head and
this is the guy that they want to go
with he's an
elitist he's an elitist and the America
First Nazis the ones
that that that would love to deport
immigrants and Jewish people and anyone
who's not them this this guy this guy's
a Jewish man it's weird I know that a
Jewish man runs and owns and operates a
Nazi
rag but it's 2024 it's weird stuff okay
it's just the timeline we're in the
timeline is not supposed to be [__]
normal all
right keep going going forward it means
that de facto Trump is the nominee if no
one could challenge him in Iowa if
nobody really has a chance of
challenging him based on the momentum
going into New Hampshire if nobody has a
challenge for him in South Carolina then
all you can say at this point is that he
is preparing for the general election
against Joe
Biden
it is January
16th all right this this video was made
last night after the caucus and Ben
Shapiro is just coming up with this
commentary that this is the reality
folks I've been telling you that this is
not a hot take this is a dumb take and
the reason why it's a dumb take is
because this take wasn't said months ago
months ago when it was realized that yes
he's the
Assumption he's the inevitable
nominee Rond STIs Nikki Haley rad damama
dingdong Christy Christie ASA Hutchinson
Tim Scott Mike Pence none of them had a
[__] chance in hell not a snowballs
chance in [__]
hell it was easy to see it's still easy
to see it it's still easy to see that
Trump's gonna run away with New
Hampshire and run away with South
Carolina and run away super
Tuesday it's just the question is is how
much money will the D owners spend to do
this now why is this important because
we need to get to the [__] facts and
some reality here to move forward
because this idea this idea that somehow
that the entire country is gonna vote
against Trump because he is gonna start
his trial on March 4th and all this
stuff folks that is that is wild that is
wildly or it's going to be 14th off
balance is [__] just boneheaded it's
the most boneheaded [__] ever it's dumb
yes I'm saying it it's as dumb as this
commentary and as dumb as this look on
his face right here stop stop stop
listening to people that are feeding you
full of a bunch of [__] stop doing
it I don't care who it is I don't give a
[__] who it is if they're just tweeting
if they're just doing shows just to
[__] just to [__] say stuff so
that they see why I I think Nikki
Haley's going to win New Hampshire
here's how she could win I'm going to go
look at the polls that the media showed
me
here stop looking at polls stop just
stop just stop we're not in a normal
timeline you don't have to go listen to
Steve
karaki give his [__]
analysis for this
race you don't you don't have to listen
to him talk about Mike Huckabee winning
in Iowa
in two th I'm not [__] you Steve
karaki last night and for the last
several days has been talking about how
Mike Huckabee won in Iowa in
2008 it's
2024 you
[__] and this this is not
normal land we do not we're not on Earth
one at least they're
not okay all right let's see here uh rad
damama dingdong speaking of rad damama
dingdong he dropped out last night I I
want to show you a screenshot and I
should get his permission um so when
Chris Christie dropped out the guy with
the last name Sanchez he text me
immediately immediately he text me and
he said Chris Christie's
out and then I I I don't know exactly
what I said I said well I I I I was
wrong on that one I thought he would be
in a lot longer I did not see that he
was I didn't think he was going to get
out before New Hampshire uh for sure I
didn't think that but so I was wrong on
that one but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
the shape shift of the numbers is
exactly the same Trump is gonna get the
exact same win that he would got if
Christie was in the wayist he will trust
me it'll his win will actually be bigger
now that Christie has left the race not
smaller everyone thinks Trump's win will
be smaller because Christie has left the
race you're [__] a you're a bonehead
V is now gone and Chris Christie's vote
will split some of it will split to
Trump I know you're like but Tony every
Chris Christie is anti-trump yes but
that's not how votes splits work that's
not how vote splits work some people
were voting for Chris Christie because
they believed what I believed that he is
the only one in the field that can beat
Joe
Biden okay regardless of what they feel
about Chris Christie saying what there's
a lot of people in New Hampshire that
would have voted for Chris Christie
because they think Chris Christie would
beat Biden period there are all sorts of
motivations for someone to vote for a
candidate in a primary that's one thing
that everyone forgets these are
primaries and how vote splits work in
primaries it's [__] these people that
you got to deal with on the
internet anyways I'll show you that here
in a minute rad damama ding-dong last
last night though oh yes my conversation
with Gabe Sanchez he asked me he asked
me who I thought would drop out next and
I can prove it I got the [__]
screenshot if anyone wants to challenge
me I said I said V name correctly yes
radama dingdong uh dropped out last
night not only did he drop out he
endorsed Trump but let's listen to a
little bit of the crying oh my God this
is great listen the first hard truth and
this one's hard for me I got to admit
he's got he he's finally gonna admit the
truth okay all right go ahead we looked
at it every which way and I think it is
true that we did not achieve the
surprise that we wanted to deliver
tonight and I think that that's just a
hard fact that we're going to have to
accept listen to rad damama dingdong
accepting those hard facts I mean dude V
Ramy dami all you had to do was just
call me man he just called Tony up just
called Tony up say Tony do I have a shot
in hell and I said not a snowball chance
[__] not a snowball chance in hell do
you have the rent Ramy Dam dingdong Ramy
dami maybe I should change the nickname
instead of Ramy damad dingdong Ramy dami
I mean we're not gonna talk about it
much going
forward we're just not he's going to try
to be relevant he's going to try to be
in Infamous here because that's what
this is about anyways it to V to Ramy
damy it was about getting [__] famous
and always when these try these people
try to be famous they end up being
Infamous um let me see if I can fast
forward it to the end because the ending
is great let's listen to the end
here and earlier tonight I called Donald
Trump to tell him that I congratulate
him on his victory listen really closely
now going forward he will have my full
endorsement
for the presc and there's a woman do you
hear Do you
hear he's like I called Trump tonight
even though I talked to him earlier in
the day and we planned this out we
totally planned this out it was a total
plan total plan for me to endorse Trump
the whole time I'm a total PL in the
Trump campaign uh most people don't know
it but my entire goal was to pull was to
make sure that the crypto Bros voted for
me and supported me online so that they
didn't support D santis so there didn't
seem like this big Coalition against
Trump for D santis it was me Ramy Dam
dingdong it was me supposed to do that
and I did and I made the most effective
moves that I could make and I'm
endorsing Trump and there's a woman in
the crowd like don't do it please don't
do
[Music]
it oh my god oh [__] I can't wait it's
going to be a great year it's going to
be a great year it really is is I
promise you that as much as you're going
to be pissed off about the media's
[__] as much as you're going to be
pissed off about some of these
commentators Miss information and their
[__] and lies it's going to be a
great [__] year it really is um and
in true style vet
cucks like a cuck cucks it's how it
works it's how it works all right uh
here's Ronda
santis in his victory
speech listen to this this is this is
even funnier listen thank you for your
support you helped us get a ticket
punched out of the Hawkeye State we have
a lot of work to do but W yeah we got
our ticket punch nine more losses and we
get a free
sandwich yeah W yeah we got our our card
punched yeah one more we get a free foot
long what the [__] is he talking
about I love it
I love the delusion this is so [__]
great oh my god listen to it again let's
go back listen thank you for your
support you helped us get a ticket
punched out of the Hawkeye State we have
a lot of work to do but I oh we got our
ticket punched
man that's no way to really talk about a
win is it oh my God Ronda
santis I just hope I just hope I just
hope these [__] donors keep spending
that money because he's vowed that he's
going to stay stay in the race he's
gonna stay in the race I do want to show
you uh the one victory speech here uh of
Grant Paul Hitler trying to talk about
Unity trying to be Miss Unity here let's
listen well I want to thank everybody
this has been some period of time and
most importantly we want to thank the
great people of Iowa thank you wait wait
wait wait wait wait I thought he thought
people in Iowa how stupid are the people
of Iowa huh so they're the great people
or the stupid people which is it Grandpa
Hitler H I don't know shut
up we love you all what a turnout what a
crowd and I really think this is time
now for everybody our country to come
together we want to come together uh
whether it's Republican or Democrat or
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait what
you want to you want to unite with the
[__] Marxist with the Communists with
the libes with the liards you want to
unite with the Deep state is that what
you're saying you want to unite with us
the Deep State okay we'll keep going
let's see if I can hear you out I'm
probably not going to do this but go
ahead or liberal or conservative it
would be so nice if we could come
together and straighten out the world
and straighten out the problems blah
blah blah blah Yaky schacky get the [__]
out of here no one's going to unify with
a bunch of [__] Nazis not going to
happen Okay you can go [__] yourself
[__] off all the way off twice I have no
more [__] to give I'm not gonna [__]
Unite with any goddamn fascist anywhere
anyhow any day not gonna happen just not
gonna happen so keep trying Grandpa go
ahead and straighten out all of the
death and destruction that we're
witnessing it's practically never been
like thisiss it's just so important and
I want to make that a very big part of
our message we're going to come together
it's going to happen soon too going to
happen we're we're gonna come together
it'll happen soon trust me when I'm
tasting dick and I'm the dick taster
only for one day and then more because
I'm the one that taste it only I can
taste it only I can taste
it only I when I'm tasting that dick
we'll all be United and if we're not
United I'll put you on a train and I'll
send you off camping you'll go to a camp
okay you knew damn well I was a snake
before you took me
in what a [__]
bonehead he's gonna unite us H all right
all right oh man [__] Trump's going
Libby soft here
liby soft liby soft uh let's see do I
have any more Clips
uh
I got one more I've got one more um rad
damama dingdong clip I want to play you
before we bury Ramy dami uh for good
here and we hopefully we won't have to
talk about this [__] for a long
time I'm sure he'll Roar his ugly head
um but oh oh here here this is this is
speaking of Iowa and then we'll go back
to the um vet clip where he's talking
into a karaoke machine I'm not kidding
you this guy this guy was talking into a
car kids karaoke machine at one of his
events but here's the the g governor of
Iowa Kim Reynolds who endorsed the loser
by the way and I don't know if you know
this um but this is very important game
it's a very important game like I showed
you the video yesterday of Tom Massie
and Chip Roy who look like they had
world record setting buyers remorse
because they knew DeSantis was going to
lose Iowa they knew he was going to lose
that's why they were because when you
endorse the [__] loser and then the
other guy wins especially when that guy
wants to be the furer and he wants to
[__] murder his denters more than
likely that's what that's what fearers
do that's what dictators do generally
speaking in an authoritarian uh
situation where they're ruling the
entire country and they you know subvert
the Constitution subvert the balance the
checks and balances and just do whatever
the [__] they want generally they start
killing people um but it's very
important that you pick the winner in
politics it's very important they pick
the winner that's why Marco Rubio waited
till yesterday that's why so many the
the the North Dakota governor waited
till yesterday so many Republicans
waited till yesterday to endorse Donald
Trump uh and because they knew he was
gonna win but if you need more evidence
that Donald Trump's gonna be the nominee
this idiot um and I do call her an idiot
because she endorsed Ronda santis she
endorsed poop Matt meatball Ron who was
clearly going to lose in Iowa there was
no chance he was going to win really
there wasn't I I promise you this um but
here she is um talking about uh Trump
being the nominee listen Governor when I
spoke to ni this morning at the diner I
love talking to people in Myers we
should do this again at the diner I know
me too one of the things I I learned
from her is that look um if if it comes
down to to Donald Trump as the nominee
I'll support him I'll support whoever
our nominee is do you share that view
does the governor governor Des sandis
share that VI well I don't you'll have
to ask Governor Des STIs that but I've
made it clear that I will I'm Republican
and you know all of the candidates
running are going to be better than what
we all the stuff he said about well
because you know we've got to put we've
got to win we I mean we are a resilient
people this country is in trouble look
at the I talked to a lot of people at
that Diner govern said this isn't worth
it to go to Trump no yeah again he's
gonna be the nominee they don't give a
[__] they're Republicans they're going
to do it so they can win and really
honestly this is the this is the
attitude that Democrats don't normally
have that liberals don't normally have
it's infuriating because they should
have a little bit of this attitude but
um all right go ahead endorse Ron the
loser and then vote for Donald Trump the
nominee fine by me fine by me now this
that was before the the caucus started
last night right before um uh let's see
now let me go back to the ramama damama
dingdong clip of him talking into a
karaoke machine and then I got another
uh God made Trump I know you don't want
to watch God made Trump I understand but
you definitely want to watch this one I
promise you I promise you you're going
to want to watch this God made Trump so
hang on to your seats but here's here's
VC watch the microphone see if you can
see it it really doesn't matter the the
the
audio you see it it's [__] a light up
it's a kids karaoke machine this
guy this guy was talking into a kid's
karaoke machine at his
event what the [__] keep going keep
going and you can tell he knows it's a
joke what a [__]
joke oh my
god oh [__] listen all right if you're a
politician out there okay and you're
showing up at a [__] event and they
and they [__] hand You A Goddamn kids
light up karaoke machine just tell them
you'll be loud just tell them you'll be
loud just say look I this not a big room
I'm sure people will hear me I'll try to
you know heighten my
volume I don't need the sweet ass Echo
that this karaoke machine
delivers this Walmart cheap ass kids
karaoke
machine
with the [__] cheesy ass Echo like
Chris B says here God damn what the
[__] oh my God these people are such
[__] Jokers man and they're so easy
like you don't I don't even have to like
mock him at
all it does the mockery does itself you
know what I mean it's so easy H it's so
easy it's [__] great and that was on
Reuters they were live streaming that
event on Reuters apparently that's where
they they grabbed the uh the
video he spent like10
million 10 million bucks in Iowa radad
dingdong
did 10 million bucks and he showed up at
an event and they [__] had him
speaking into a goddamn Light Up wmart
Style cheap ass kids karaoke
machine what the [__] okay all right all
right that's that's cool I guess that's
I guess all the all the [__] [__]
all the crypto Bros on Twitter that gave
to his campaign all the blue checks
they're not just dumb because they have
blue checks they're dumb because they
give their money to people like rad
damama dingdong to show up at a campaign
event and talking to a karaoke a light
up karaoke
machine whoosh all right that's good all
right um this God made Trump thing we
watched uh God made Trump we watched God
made a farmer last week too and we
compared the two and we talked about
what white Christian nationalism is and
what Christian nationalism is and what
the difference is between their
motivations there's a brand new God made
Trump released I know you probably don't
want to watch it but trust me you're
gonna want to hang on here do not do not
leave you're gonna want to watch this
I'm telling you it is God made Trump
smell let's
listen and on June 14th 19 46 God lost a
bet with Satan and Satan said pay up so
God made Trump God said I need someone
willing to get up before Dawn to call
Fox and Friends hypnotize Brian kill me
beg for money bang a porn star get
someone killed pay off a born star and
tweet until noon until he stumbles into
work wearing a Big Mac like an alien
face hugger so God gave us Trump God
said I need a sweaty swindler with arms
long enough to cheat at golf but hands
small enough to order off the kids menu
someone who could sell [__] to a [__]
hole or a [__] ring to loo Jones at a
purity ring kiosk flatulate fraud to
wanka warmonger shanka translator fet
potentate hide a bone saw sell a secret
come home hungry stop at KFC promise to
pay for everyone's meals duck the check
call the first lady having lunch with
friends in a different state then tell
the Ladi she needs a moment alone with
the first lady because she should
probably get tested for hepatitis come
back soon ladies especially the ones
with Behemoth bazongas so God give us I
need a Savage Beast sued by Kid Rock
Whistling Dixie bewildered by water
incontinent enough to wear a x c diaper
secured by exoskeletal girdle hydraulic
lift and bioweapons containment team
willing to give their lives for the love
child of a hapsburg inbread and a
necrotic squash a Flim Flam panderer who
can turn [__] to gold gold to [__]
soybean Farmers to w a wreaking Rake who
can't read but speaks in tongues
manifesting mind comp like a Ridin
roused Ronda bur Uber mench so God gave
us Trump God said I need a tacky
trickster who writes like a fourth
grader talks like a third grader cheats
like a fornicator brags like a
compensator and dresses like a head
waiter who wears golf cleats to church a
louse who leans 60° and 3in lifts
waddling down a ramp grabbing a steering
wheel chear gassing a book club with the
FedEd charnal house miasma of splenetic
emissions escaping his manly sweat
glands and ass pores all the while
bankrupting a casino chiseling the
Secret Service stealing government
staplers losing a lawsuit inciting a
riot looking up his daughter's skirt
with shoe mirrors and on a Bible so God
made Trum and God said I need an
absentee father dead beat de vengeful
vulgarian to be my Champion with a
golden Mane and the Maine shall extend a
hands breath below the ear on the right
one cubit below the ear on the left two
cubits from the crown to the upper back
the back shall be fire hosed forward
transected like a lattice crust of the
world's rankest pork pie red back and
secured with the least woke hair product
from among the Canaanites but the bald
patch in the center of the garden you
shall not touch for it is Holy to the
Lord the stimulus of comx
activity oh my God thank you at history
Falls uh main that video thank you very
much we actually uh ripped it and put it
on our YouTube channel a yeah I don't
give a [__] that's the internet baby if
you put it out there I'm gonna steal it
I'm gonna put it on the internet so that
you can see it too I'm GNA show it to
everyone that I can possibly show it to
if you got something good as long as
you're not going to copyright strike me
or some [__] but history Falls at
history Falls you can follow him on on
Twitter it's a great video and we post
on a YouTube channel so don't for get to
subscribe to the YouTube channel don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel right now that's right you can
hit the Subscribe button it's somewhere
down there or you can come over and
subscribe to the YouTube channel and you
can watch that video on the YouTube
channel and you can share it around
that's what you should be doing share it
around you share around actually you can
go to the Tony michaels.com let me show
you how to do that you go to Theon
michaels.com at the very top hit
subscribe pan on down give some money to
the tattoo live stream to the team
tattoo fund that way you can watch the
live stream pan on down join join the
patreon join the Discord link your
Amazon to your Twitch account and then
hit the YouTube channel button and then
you'll find that video so do all
that do all of
that oh my God it's such a great
video gotta hang on to that one keep
playing that one holy smokes all right
let's move on to some other [__] eaters
here um I don't know we on Sunday um I
showed you a video of Taylor
Swift um
now I I I wasn't going to do this
yesterday because we had a lot of work
to do when we described the pizza
delivery boy uh delivering the
pizza so and we had Jess Piper on
yesterday too so I had to make time for
that but I've got I've got this um
Taylor Swift video that I want to show
you she was having fun at the NFL game
um at the Chiefs playoff game or the
Chiefs W on Sunday now her boyfriend the
person she's [__] is the tight end
for the Kansas City Chiefs right and
she's having fun look at her she's
having fun oh uh yeah whooo yeah it's an
NFL game they're playing music it's like
a commercial break and everyone in the
crowd is doing the same thing she's
doing and she's hyping and they're
playing her on screen because she's the
most famous person on the planet and
she's at the game so they want to get
people all [__] hyped up and they
were they were hyped up the crowd was
going wild the Kansas City Chiefs won
the
playoff game
technically oh Patrick Mahomes has more
playoff wins than [__] Aaron Rodgers
which really pisses all these [__]
eaters off there's a lot of things to be
excited about in that video right lot of
things to be excited about
there's a lot of things I want to show
you another video from another playoff
game now the shade eaters were super
pissed off they were super [__]
pissed off about that video of Taylor
Swift having fun how dare she have fun
at a football game what are you what are
you some kind of
American having fun at a football game
you [__] piece of [__] what the [__]
else are you supposed to do besides
having [__] fun at a football game
you [__] [__]
ERS well let me tell you what they had
the same energy the exact same energy
for this guy I don't know if you know
who this guy
is this is Eminem this is Eminem and he
was at the Detroit Lions game because
he's he's from he's from Detroit he's
from Detroit now he isn't [__] a
football player you know I give him that
I'll give him that Eminem is not [__]
the tight end of the Lions he's not
doing that but he is a lions fan and he
was a really famous person like him and
is a super famous
person at the football gam so they
played him on the Jumbotron and the
reason why is to I don't know um
probably hype the crowd and get loud
hype the crowd and get loud
right no they weren't outraged by Eminem
I wonder what it could be I wonder if
it's because Eminem has a dick I wonder
if that's what it could be I wonder if
it's and and because Eminem doesn't like
post on his Instagram post for people to
go to to register to vote and and they
go and hundreds of thousands of people
go to register to vot they probably what
it could be well let's let's let's hear
what these [__] idiots have to say
about about Taylor Swift let's see if
they can give us any insight something
about this it just it just feels forced
and it is my hope that Taylor Swift
sticks to just doing music I I think
it's gonna be bad for her brand I mean
not that oh man yeah Charlie Kirk is is
giving [__] advice career advice to
Taylor
Swift okay now if you don't know who
Charlie Kirk is Charlie Kirk is a radio
host he's a talking head but he's also
the head of the turning points USA he's
the founder of the turning points USA
now the turning points USA isn't
actually a
business well per se he has to get get
rich people to give him money so he can
go brainwash young people into believing
what the rich people want them to
believe that's the business that Charlie
Kirk's in he goes and he gets money
given to him to go produce brainwashed
young people that's the whole point of
turning points USA the entire point the
whole thing it's what he
does so I don't know that Taylor swi to
really be taking [__] business advice
from Charles but go ahead Charles I'm
want to give her advice she she's stayed
away from a lot of this stuff I hope she
does this coming fall but we better be
on guard because she could be an
unbelievable asset for Biden and the
Democrat Party oh she could be an
unbelievable asset see that's what
they're scared of they're scared of
what's gonna happen is that Charlie Kirk
Charlie Kirk and these other [__] eaters
who hate Taylor Swift for going to a
football game they're hating on her for
going to a football game and the reason
why is because it normalizes her to
people who watch
football that's what they're terrified
of see art is a special thing it's not
like what I do I mean what I do is kind
of an art right I am performing to some
degree I come here every day it's a
two-hour thing I talk without taking any
[__] breaks or pauses almost
whatsoever for an entire two hours I
don't sit and read the chat make sure
that you guys tell me what you want to
say uh what am I supposed to say next
what does the chat say what am I
supposed to say next when and look at
the chat
in drink my my drink the entire time no
I'm a commentator I'm an Entertainer to
some degree that's the whole point I
have to keep your attention for two full
hours every single day so I gotta do it
right and I gotta rant there's some
[__] skill to this some talent to it
but I refrain from calling it exactly
art like Taylor Swift's art is Art music
is art oh my God music is [__] art
and music actually can send almost a
better
message and get more people coales
behind an idea than almost any piece of
art almost
any think about it a music is a song is
is small it's a small part of your time
it's so small right it's not two hours
that you got got to come watch every
single [__] day and you record the
song once and you record it perfectly
then you can just play it over and over
and over and over and over again
especially if it's a really good catchy
[__]
song People start to pay
attention people start to really kind of
like those songs and that music and they
kind of like the person that sings them
so much so that they'll actually listen
to them when they talk and they say
things it's incredible and that's what
Charlie's really [__] terrified of
Charlie's terrified that Taylor Swift is
going to look at her fans the swifties
who are in general young women or women
in general there's some dudes that love
Taylor Swift I'm not saying that there's
not dudes that don't love Taylor Swift
music I'm I am not a fan of Taylor Swift
music like I don't listen to it I don't
own her albums I mean I mean I know a
Taylor Swift song when I kind of hear it
but I don't know any specific songs I
just that's not the kind of music that I
listen to it's okay it's it's not a bad
thing everyone has their preferences but
he's terrified he's terrified that young
women are gonna listen to this music
they're gonna love her and then when she
says go register to vote they're going
to register to vote and then when
they're like who do we vote for like
someone who won't take away your rights
and they're like oh so you mean not
Republicans she's like yeah not
Republicans they definitely want to take
your [__] rights they want to make
you second class citizens that's what
want to do like Charlie Kirk wants to
make women second class citizens they
they he would prefer that women be
property like they used to be you not
not have a vote not have the right to
own property not have the right to have
a bank account you know that used to be
a [__] thing in this country and
Charlie Kirk would like to get back to
those good old days and Taylor Swift is
a threat to that Taylor Swift is a
threat to that because she liberates
young
women just by example she liberates
young women and with her voice and her
influence she liberates young women that
terrifies the [__] out of these fragile
white Christian
nationalists [__] terrifies the [__]
out of
them scares them beyond
belief because they
know they know that Taylor Swift snaps
her [__]
fingers and people will listen to
her I got to work really hard really
[__] hard to get a couple thousand
people to watch me live every day it's
difficult for two hours the entire time
that's some difficult [__] Charlie ears
same way he's gotta work really hard to
get a lot of people to watch him every
single day for two hours Taylor Swift
posts one post I mean I could tell you
guys go register to vote go register to
vote go register to vote go register to
vote and I I would be lucky to get
10,000 people to register to vote over a
several year period because I say it out
loud and you should you should register
to vote not only should you register to
vote you should go register people to
vote you should ask them are you
registered to vote doesn't matter who
they are doesn't matter who they'll vote
for you should ask them are you
registered to vote it is the most sacred
right that we have in this country to
participate and engage in our democracy
it really truly is everyone thinks it's
the freedom of speech but it's the right
to
vote it's who we choose that votes for
us that matters because they could take
away our [__] rights we know that
that's what Charlie wants and that's why
he's scared of Taylor because Taylor can
say go vote for someone who won't take
away your rights and it definitely won't
be someone that Charlie wants them to
vote
for speaking of music and art a great
artist that I I I love this guy this guy
has got great music um he plays a lot of
Bluegrass and a lot of strings he's a
[__] goat the goat on the acoustic
guitar and I know a lot of people
probably haven't heard of of him he's
getting more and more popular and more
and PE more people are knowing him um
but he wrote a song
recently about Taylor Swift now what
happened was is Taylor Swift has a movie
out about her concert I don't know if
you guys know this has a movie out about
her con about her concert and so it's
playing in a lot of theaters now this
[__] thing is making bank I mean Bank
like just [__] mountains of money
like she's so [__] rich like she's so
[__] rich B it's not even
funny so much money like you go into the
theater and there's a little sign
they're like hey the Taylor Swift thing
yeah that's a way more expensive ticket
price and it's non-refundable and you
better get them now because they're
going to go They're Not Gonna Last
right a big step fan says she's rich
[__] that's right she's rich [__] it's
true now in these theaters you know they
hang a poster of the [__] movie you know
the movie posters in the theater well
someone in Tulsa Oklahoma who was
wearing a billy strings hat again if you
don't know who Billy strings is he's a
great he's a great artist he's a [__]
phen again I think he's the goat on the
acoustic guitar there's a lot of [__]
people that play the acoustic guitar
well but this guy hands down Billy
strings there's a reason why he's called
Billy strings is because [__]
can string it it is [__] man he can
[__] he can light them on fire and
you're going to see that in this video
but one of his fans who was wearing one
of his hats like his merch hats
stole a Taylor Swift poster in Tulsa
Oklahoma stole it from the theater
ripped it Down Right likely because they
weren't a fan of Taylor
Swift now the Tulsa the Tulsa Police
Department is looking for this person
now let me show you that here in the
video the Tulsa Police Department
tweeted out they said need your help
Iden ID ifying this Swifty they put
quotes around it because they know this
person is against Taylor not for him
this person of interest is apparently of
fan when a little extreme to get the
souvenir of his favorite performer on
1112 2023 this person in the photos
wearing a quote black Billy strings hat
cap excuse me entered the AMC theater at
Olympic
Avenue so tore down a sign but of course
Billy's getting a lot of [__] online
because the guy had his hat on so Billy
does what Billy does best and an artist
does what an artist does best just like
Taylor does what Taylor does best is Art
and singing and sending a message with
their Art here's Billy strings singing
about that guy stealing the Taylor Swift
poster listen to
Billy down in Tulsa Oklahoma there's a
movie theater there they play lots of
movies from Step Brothers to con and
they've been playing concerts that old
Taylor Swift has done and old boy walked
in and ripped a poer down
from now the cops are looking for him
and they don't know where he's at they
CAU him on the camera in his Navy Billy
Hat everybody's wondering where
the I Ione what these folks
do my friends I don't condone taking
things that t in a movie theater down in
town it don't belong to you to watch you
well you should have left that poster on
the
[Music]
wall Billy
strings sending art all across all
across across the interwebs to tell you
the story about the person who stole the
Taylor Swift poster telling the swifties
out there that he's as not condone what
these people do leave your sh leave that
[__] alone leave it up on the wall
Billy's not only a great artist but he's
a decent dude decent dude and you should
go follow Billy strings right now uh
everywhere across the internet whether
it's YouTube just just go to Google and
type in Billy strings after the show
we're almost done don't don't go
anywhere yet but type in Billy
strings when you guys leave here go to
his YouTube channel go to his Facebook
wherever wherever you guys social media
You're Gonna Love Billy's music you're
gon to love his attitude you're gonna
love him picking and a digging uh
because uh Billy knows how to pick and
uh he brings a new voice and a new style
to Bluegrass in country in this country
and he's beginning to be more and more
and more popular uh so go check out and
he's real he's a real authentic person
he's had trouble with ADD and drugs he
admits it he talks about it he sings
about it um so Billy is a genuine artist
and a genuine guy so thanks Billy for
that for that video and thank you for
joining me here on this Tuesday January
16th the day after Trump pathetically
wins the
caucus and he's going to continue to win
he's going to be the nominee that's how
it's GNA be that's how it's gonna be I'm
calling it I'm predicting he's going to
win New Hampshire he's going to go on to
win South Carolina and super
Tuesday
that's just how it's going to happen
trust me I know stay tuned don't go
anywhere come back make sure you're
watching the show every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube the books of face the twitch
machine and the
Instagrams same time same place tomorrow
Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking June 14th 1946 God lost a bet
with Satan and Satan said pay up so God
made Trump God said I need someone
willing to get up before Dawn to call
Fox and Friends hypnotize Brian kilme
beg for money bang a born dog get
someone killed pay off a born star and
tweet until noon until he stumbles into
work wearing a Big Mac like an alien
face hugger so God gave us Trump God
said I need a sweaty swindler with arms
long enough to cheat at golf but hands
small enough to order off the kids menu
someone who could sell [__] to a [__]
hole or a [__] ring to L Jones at a
purity ring kiosk flatlet fraud to wanka
warmonger shanka translator fet
potentate hi to Bon saw sell a secret
come home hungry stop at KFC promise to
pay for everyone's meals duck the check
call the first lady having lunch with
friends and a different state then tell
the ladies he needs a moment alone with
the first lady because she should
probably get tested for hepatitis and to
be sure to come back real soon ladies
especially the ones with Behemoth
bazongas so God gave us Trump I need a
Savage Beast soothed by Kid Rock
Whistling Dixie bewildered by water
incontinent enough to wear a triple X
cell diaper secured by exoskeletal
girdle hydraulic lift and bioweapons
containment team willing to give their
lives for the love child of a hapsburg
inbred and a necrotic squash a Flim Flam
panderer who can turn [__] to gold gold
to [__] soybean Farmers to welfare
Queens a wreaking Rake who can't read
but speaks in tongues manifesting mine
comp like a riddlin roused Ronda bur
Uber mench so God gave us Trump God said
I need a tacky trickster who writes like
a fourth grader talks like a third
grader cheats like a fornicator brags
like a compensator and dresses like a
head waiter who wears golf cleats to
church a Lous who leans 60° and 3in
lifts waddling down a ramp grabbing a
steering wheel cheer gassing a book club
with the FedEd charnal house miasma of
spinetic emission escaping his manly
sweat glands and ass pores all the while
bankrupting a casino chiseling the
Secret Service stealing government
staplers losing a lawsuit inciting a
riot looking up his daughter's skirt
with shoe mirrors and masturbating on a
Bible so God made Trump and God said I
need an absentee father dead beat D
vengeful vulgarian to be my Champion
with a golden Mane and the Maine shall
extend a hands breath below the ear on
the right one cubit below the ear on the
left two cubits from the crown to the
upper back the back shall be fire hose
Ed forward transected like a lattice
crust of the world's rankest pork pie
raked back and secured with the least
woke hair product from among the
Canaanites but the bald patch in the
center of the garden you shall not touch
for it is Holy to the Lord sight or
sound as the stimulus to convex
activities